sa seule valeur vous est personnelle
et j'adore cela.
J'ai tendance à graviter vers des tatouages très colorés
car la couleur m'obsède.
J'enseigne un cours à ce sujet à l'université.
Mais mon tout premier tatouage était un tatouage noir,
comme ceux d'Ötzi.
Oui, j'ai fait cette chose clichée que les jeunes font parfois
et je me suis fait un tatouage dans une langue que je ne sais pas lire.
(Rires)
Mais j'avais 19 ans,
je venais de revenir de mon premier voyage à l'étranger,
j'avais été au Japon, dans les montagnes,
à méditer dans des monastères bouddhistes
et cette expérience était importante pour moi,
alors j'ai voulu la commémorer avec ce caractère japonais et chinois
pour « montagne ».
Voici ce qui m'impressionne :
mon tatouage qui a 14 ans
et les tatouages d'Ötzi qui ont 5 300 ans
sont faits avec la même chose :
de la suie,
cette poussière de carbone noire et poudreuse
qui reste dans la cheminée quand vous brûlez des choses.
Si vous zoomez sur mon tatouage ou les tatouages d'Ötzi,
vous découvrirez qu'ils ressemblent tous à ceci.
Un tatouage n'est rien de plus qu'un tas de petites particules de pigment,
de la suie dans ce cas-là,
coincées dans le derme,
la couche de tissu juste en-dessous de la surface de la peau.
En plus de 5 000 ans,
nous avons fait très peu pour moderniser la technologie des tatouages,
à part avoir accès à plus de couleurs
et à des méthodes de pose légèrement plus efficaces.
Si je suis un artiste, je suis aussi un scientifique
et je dirige un laboratoire de recherche en nanotechnologie,
la science de la création d'objets avec des composants extrêmement petits,
des milliers de fois plus petits que la largeur d'un cheveu humain.
J'ai commencé à me demander :
comment la nanotechnologie pouvait-elle se mettre au service du tatouage ?
Si les tatouages ne sont qu'un tas de particules dans la peau,
pouvions-nous remplacer ces particules
par d'autres faisant quelque chose de plus intéressant ?
Voici ma grande idée :
je crois que les tatouages peuvent vous donner des super-pouvoirs.
(Rires)
Je ne veux pas dire qu'ils vont nous faire voler,
mais nous pouvons avoir des super-pouvoirs
dans le sens où les tatouages peuvent nous doter de nouvelles capacités
que nous ne possédons pas actuellement.
En améliorant les particules, nous pouvons créer un tatouage
qui changera non seulement l'apparence de notre peau,
mais aussi le rôle de notre peau.
Laissez-moi vous montrer.
Voici un diagramme d'une microcapsule.
C'est une petite particule creuse avec une enveloppe protectrice,
de la taille d'un pigment de tatouage,
et vous pouvez la remplir avec ce que vous voulez, ou presque.
Et si nous mettions des substances intéressantes
dans ces microcapsules
et en faisions des encres de tatouage ?
Quel genre de choses pourrions-nous faire faire à un tatouage ?
Quels problèmes pourrions-nous résoudre ?
Quelles limites humaines pourrions-nous surmonter ?
Voici une idée :
une de nos faiblesses d'humains
est que nous ne pouvons pas voir la lumière ultraviolette, ou UV.
C'est la partie haute en énergie de la lumière du soleil
qui entraîne les coups de soleil
et accroît nos risques de cancer de la peau.
De nombreux animaux et insectes peuvent voir la lumière UV, mais pas nous.
Si nous le pouvions, nous pourrions voir la crème solaire sur notre peau.
Malheureusement, la plupart d'entre nous ne mettent pas de crème solaire
et ceux qui en mettent
ne savent pas quand elle se dissipe car elle est invisible.
C'est principalement pourquoi
nous traitons cinq millions de cancers de la peau évitables
chaque année aux États-Unis uniquement,
ce qui coûte à notre économie plus de cinq milliards de dollars par an.
Comment pourrions-nous surmonter cette faiblesse humaine avec un tatouage ?
Si le problème est que nous ne pouvons pas voir les rayons UV,
peut-être pouvons-nous créer un tatouage qui les détecte pour nous.
Je me suis dit : pourquoi ne pas prendre des microcapsules,
les remplir d'un colorant sensible aux UV et changeant de couleur
et en faire de l'encre de tatouage ?
L'un des problèmes quand on est un technologue des tatouages
est de trouver des volontaires pour servir de cobayes.
(Rires)
Quand est venu le moment de tester cette encre de tatouage,
j'ai trouvé préférable de ne pas torturer mes pauvres étudiants universitaires.
Alors j'ai décidé de tatouer quelques points sur mon bras.
Et cela a fonctionné, regardez !
J'appelle ces tatouages des taches solaires
car ils fonctionnent grâce au soleil.
Actuellement, ils sont invisibles,
mais dès que je les expose à une lampe UV tenant le rôle du Soleil --
les voilà, des points bleus.
Je n'ai pas de crème solaire dans cette vidéo,
mais si j'en avais, ces points bleus n'apparaîtraient pas
et quand, plus tard, ma crème solaire se dissiperait,
les taches solaires réapparaîtraient à la lumière UV
et je saurais qu'il est temps de remettre de la crème solaire.
Ces tatouages ont un rôle d'indicateur en temps réel et à l’œil nu
de l'exposition de votre peau aux UV.
Bien sûr,
je pense que vous pourriez faire de nombreuses choses cool et artistiques
avec un tatouage changeant ainsi de couleur,
mais j'espère aussi qu'il nous aidera à résoudre un gros problème
de protection de la peau.
(Applaudissements)
Laissez-moi vous donner un autre exemple.
La température normale du corps humain est entre 36°C et 37,5°C
et si vous sortez de cette fourchette,
vous devez immédiatement consulter un médecin.
Le problème est que les humains ne peuvent pas détecter
la température de leur corps sans thermomètre.
Vous pouvez essayer l'astuce de la main sur le front,
mais il n'y a aucune preuve scientifique pour appuyer cela.
(Rires)
Et si nous pouvions créer un thermomètre à tatouer
auquel vous pourriez accéder n'importe quand ?
Vous vous souvenez
comment les taches solaires utilisaient un colorant sensible aux UV
dans les microcapsules de l'encre de tatouage ?
Vous pourriez mettre des colorants sensibles à la chaleur
dans les microcapsules
et créer différentes encres de tatouage
qui changent de couleur à différentes températures.
Supposons que ce soit 36°C, 37°C et 38°C.
Si vous mettez ces encres côte à côte,
vous avez une échelle de température
adaptée au corps humain.
Dans cette vidéo, vous voyez différentes taches de tatouage
disparaître de façon séquentielle
alors que la peau de cochon de nos tests
est chauffée.
Si vous placiez un tel tatouage
dans un endroit insensible aux variations extérieures de température --
peut-être dans la bouche, à l'intérieur de la lèvre --
vous seriez capable de lire votre température corporelle
simplement en regardant votre tatouage dans un miroir.
Génial, n'est-ce pas ?
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Une autre limitation que nous avons
est que notre peau ne conduit pas l'électricité
et cela peut être une bonne chose, mais pas nécessairement --
(Rires)
si vous avez un implant biomédical électronique,
comme un pacemaker par exemple.
Actuellement, si vous avez un pacemaker,
vous avez besoin d'une opération tous les cinq ou dix ans
pour remplacer la batterie.
Ne serait-il pas sympa si, au lieu de cela,
nous pouvions recharger la batterie via un bout de peau conductrice ?
Si vous pouviez régler ce problème avec un tatouage,
la première étape serait de créer un tatouage conduisant l'électricité.
Nous travaillons sur une encre de tatouage conductrice dans mon labo.
Actuellement, nous sommes capables d'augmenter la conductivité de notre peau
par un facteur de 300 avec notre encre de tatouage conductrice.
Le chemin est encore long avant d'en arriver à la conductivité
d'un fil de cuivre par exemple,
mais nous faisons des progrès et je suis très enthousiaste
car je crois que cela pourrait ouvrir un monde de possibilités
pour les tatouages.
J'imagine un futur où les tatouages nous permettent --
des câbles et de l'électronique à tatouer nous permettent
de fusionner nos technologies et nos corps
afin que cela semble être plus une extension de nous-mêmes
qu'un appareil externe.
Voilà quelques exemples de capacités que nous pouvons obtenir
en utilisant la nanotechnologie pour améliorer nos tatouages,
mais ce n'est que le début.
Je pense qu'il n'y a pas de limite
à ce que nous pouvons faire avec des tatouages high-tech.
A l'avenir, les tatouages ne seront pas que beaux,
ils seront aussi fonctionnels.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)